Dù rồi, trình gặp nó sẽ gặp.
Lúc gặp lại đi làm nước mắm, gì lại được rồi?
Chẳng không có trình gặp, không có trình gặp là người mẹ đã đoàn xanh được.
Hãy là để được một khán thay tháng mà để đúng là nó cũng có hơn đồ dọ.
Cô nền gặp em tất nhiên qua hỗ trình gà, cũng được được rồi.
Rồi rồi, nó, dạy, chíy nhờ bố ăn.
Cô bẩy nó đảm đặt không.
Điểm trường này là nó đẹp để có thấy cũng sợ tạy.
Dạ có hồ hợp này là có sợi này không sù cũng hãy chăm.
Thôi nhiều, hôm qua mình sẽ trải qua của phía mình đi ra
Dù của tôi như màu được cái món mình thốt,
Anh dưới mà nữa thì bây giờ cũng đáng
Thật chức mung trứng gài là giải mám đốt
Chứ là giân trạn
Đây được cái sạch sợi là ngon tạm đà
Mấy đúng không?
Đó cả thì hợp lấy là chức lượng không?
Chúng không? Cái khách là ngay đây là đánh đà
Đúng không? Cái khách là ngon?